bauvorhaben gemacht dass vereine das ist
klar sind eigentliche motoren der
integration und an erster stelle steht
natürlich fußball
immer häufiger sind wird auch die
mädchen die kicken wollen wir haben
zugeschaut bei den juniorinnen des sport
club zürich wipkingen und schnell
gemerkt da wird nicht nur der
flankenschutz gibt sondern auch die
sozialkompetenz united nations in der
mädchen garderobe dreimal die woche
trainieren diese fußball juniorinnen mit
unterschiedlichsten sozialen und
kulturellen hintergrund zwölf nationen
kicken allein dieser mannschaft
[Musik]
sportlich verbrauch portugal langsam
meine beiden eltern kommen aus
deutschland
diese media widmet sich ein ledern heißt
nicht gleich machen
im fußball ist vielfalt wie stärke und
teamgeist alle im training werden die
spielerinnen gefordert und gefördert und
immer verbindet das spiel mit dem ball
[Musik]
trainer kennt die integrationskosten
fußball
er hat die juniorinnen keeper vor acht
jahren gegründet innere gruppe wieder
für viel kritik ist wichtig dass maria
akzeptanz hat sie die andere die für
ihre kultur mitbringen sich ok sowie
sind und mein name service wins
bietigheimer gemeinsam ihre beste chance
fast wie im richtigen leben es ist ein
lernen die mikrokosmos fußballvereins
sozialer kompetenzen stärken für
anerkennung kämpfen sich gravierend als
ich hier kommen alle frauen weiter offen
gute möglichkeiten zu haben
für eine sekunde bedeutet mit beispielen
doppelte herausforderung aber auch
doppelte heute aus rollenbildern
ausbrechen dem elternhaus widersetzen
wenn eltern finden fußball sich nicht
für mädchen und schule da wichtiger als
sport vermittelt so nah der trainer mit
seiner kräfte verbraucht weniger den
sieg an das gilt die integration als
vielmehr den eltern
das geschieht am neben dem fußballplatz
an vereins anlässen wie einem sponsor
einen kontakt oder spanien
kleine schritte in richtung
weltoffenheit doch der eine oder andere
kulturelle unterschied bleibt doch sogar
die schweizerinnen lassen sich mit der
zeit ganz anständig integrieren
die reagierte so wie mir also die
positive mir aus kann ich spiele
zusammen spielen zusammen stark sein
dieser mädchenbande trainiert es dreimal
die woche
[Musik]